return of the mood bürger ein schwerer
schock vor allem für die cdu und
tatsächlich hat die partei im keller des
kanzleramts gerade ein forschungslabor
eingerichtet um die bedrohliche spezies
wutbürger endlich besser zu verstehen
dr birte schneider leitet das projekt
fordert schneider was haben sie denn das
jetzt herausgefunden welche da gibt es
eine ganz interessante neue studie der
hans-böckler-stiftung nach der sind zb
afd anhänger im wesentlichen männer die
finden dass zu wenig auf sie gehört wird
oder kurz gesagt männer mittelalte
männer die sehr sehr wütend sind oder
deren lautstärke regler kaputt ist wir
suchen jetzt im auftrag des kanzleramts
verzweifelt nach möglichkeiten diese
leute bis zur wahl wieder zu beruhigen
ich habe alles versucht marschmusik
dosenbier hoffmann begrüßungsgeld null
reaktion
da herrscht eine art dauer panik die wir
überhaupt nicht mehr den griff kriegen
die befürchten nämlich dass das
sämtliche zehn milliarden menschen auf
dieser welt hier in deutschland in den
sozialstaat einwandern können zehn
milliarden kommen
es gibt auf der erde doch nur
siebeneinhalb egal kommen durch die
einseitige nutzung seiner ganz rechten
gehirnhälfte sind andere gehirnareale
leider total verkümmert wie viele finger
halte ich hoch zu jagen
herr welke wir tun doch hinter den
kulissen schon alles um diesen wächst
wutbürgern zu gefallen
thomas de maizière will sozialleistungen
für asylbewerber kürzen
wir machen gerade deals mit den
schlimmsten diktatoren afrikas in libyen
bezahlen die kriminelle damit die für
uns die flüchtlinge im lager sperren
echt jetzt verhängen die nicht mehr im
mittelmeer sondern in der sahara
wir dachten so was lieben wutbürger aber
die sind immer noch wütend versuche es
jetzt nochmal mit beruhigenden bildern
so mein süßer was haben wir denn hier
grenzzäune in ungarn blonde deutsche
kinder
und was ganz besonderes eine niedliche
katze leute das ist eine person
[Applaus]